this bowl like I said a second ago I
really want to congratulate you on the
moving it's fantastic uh and thank you
for giving me your time today oh you're
very welcome and I'm I'm so happy you
enjoyed it uh so I like throwing you
off ball uh you know curves at the
beginning
um if someone is actually never seen
anything that you've made before what is
the first thing you want them watching
and why oh wow
wow
the first thing I want them watching
well
what you're what you're really saying is
what's your the work you're proudest of
I guess now not necessarily it's like
you because you've made a number of
movies if someone has never seen any
what's the one you want them to start
with no it's a great question I mean you
know what it's it the movies take on a
strange role in your life
as kind of like almost like your
children uh and and and
you see at that web and I have three
children I don't know if you have
children I have three children whom I
love so much I want to eat them and the
idea that you know I I love one more
than the other or the one's more
interesting or I would start with one of
it it's impossible I would never I mean
I love them equally
and
probably not I probably don't love all
of them the same
but I do love them equally and the same
goes for
movies I
maybe maybe this one because it's a a
strange way a kind of origin
Story I mean origin's story is so
pompous because it sounds almost like a
a movie that's about self-aggrandizement
you know how the young kid became some
terrific artist in the world but as you
know from having seen the film that the
ambition of the movie is very different
from that and and I I don't necessarily
always hold myself in the most beautiful
light which I thought was very important
to be honest with the audience but I
think that that aspect of it may be why
it's the best to introduce somebody to
the work
it's a great question you ask I've never
been asked that before I'm not that's
part of the reason probably why I'm
answering in a rather uh goofy fashion
but I I would say that maybe this one
because
it's the most personal
and the clearest line to who I am or
certainly who I was
and you can see the work that results I
I suppose it's interesting though
because
Armageddon time is a story about your
childhood and a moment but I don't know
if you've seen a Spielberg movie yet but
Fable men's is the Spielberg origin
story I haven't you know he's a such a
great director I mean I I'm dying to see
it first of all
um there's nobody who understands where
to put the camera better than that guy
and uh
it's so weird to me and so cool to be
that someone of his stature and level of
accomplishment would make uh a sort of
coming of age of buildings Roman or
whatever you want to call it uh around
the same moment that mine's coming out
and I'm sure they have to be because
they're both personal quite different
because there's only one of you you know
so I'm I I have you seen the movie I
haven't yeah I was at Tiff I saw a lot
of movies
it's completely different than yours
yeah I haven't I just haven't seen it
and I'm so I've been asked about it now
and it's frustrating me because I'm an
idiot I I haven't had a chance to see
any movies let alone that one but I'm so
curious and I I am really in love with
his work and I think he's just uh like I
said you can't get any better at knowing
where to put the camera than I had a
stage a scene than Spielberg so I'm
curious to see what he did I can't speak
to it thematically though I have no idea
what it is yeah I also it only played a
tiff so there's been no opportunity to
see it it's not like it's playing at the
multiplex right now but anyway
um which of your films changed the most
in the editing room in ways you did not
expect
oh this is so these are great uh
probably
a movie I did called The Yards the the
way that that was conceived was as
having multiple points of view about one
event which was this
moment in the train yards and then you
would see all these different characters
points of view but when I cut it
together it didn't work to switch points
of view because there was no connective
tissue well in other words it wasn't
like they were all in the same family I
think I used Rocco and his brothers as a
template but it didn't work because they
weren't Brothers
so then I had to re-fashion the whole
thing through Mark Wahlberg's point of
view and that took a lot of
editorial sleight of hand
so I would say that one and that you
know it's been a while since I made that
film but that I I think I learned more
on that movie than I've ever learned
about anything in my in in all of uh my
Endeavors but but honestly Stephen
sometimes you learn hugely from failure
from what doesn't work and success is
entirely uh
unhelpful because you know you you as
strange as that sounds you know you when
you when you're so
successful at something I could imagine
I've never really felt this way I can
imagine that it would be its own form of
pressure like what do you do like how do
you follow up like let's say you're like
uh I don't know uh
well let's say you're Spielberg right
you've just made jaws and close
encounters and then then what do you do
I mean that's its own pressure or or
William friedkin in the 70s after he
made the French Connection and The
Exorcist now I think sorcerer is a
fantastic movie but it was must have
been
it must have you know scrambled
somebody's brain to know what to do
so uh on the yards I remember the key
failings of the script on a narrative
level a point of view level
and uh really learning from that about
how important point of view is in
narrative is that the film that you
ended up with the most deleted scenes uh
of all your films yeah no question
because of exactly that reason I had a
bunch of great stuff with James Khan
who was so brilliant I mean I had all
this great detail work with him and
talking with all these Borough president
type people and and she followed his day
as he would wake up in the morning and
he was so great in the movie
and unfortunately it all had to
it all had to hit The Cutting Room floor
I remember feeling like I'd let him down
it was a bad feeling I I listen I think
that uh I've spoken to a lot of
directors and I always ask them about
like what's it like speaking to a
younger actor who had a bigger part
ultimately ended up on The Cutting Room
floor what is that phone call like to
call them and say you did amazing work
but like most of your scenes are not
going to be seen
it's it's awful and may I say I have
been at times too self-obsessed busy or
chicken or any combination of the three
sometimes to let the actor know
and I've worked with some great actors
who have been cut out of movies I don't
think I've in fact I'm going to say this
I don't think I've ever cut out
an actor from a movie because the actor
wasn't any good
it's almost entirely because there's
narrative demands point of view demands
and structure demands that enforce that
on you it's it's deeply frustrating and
you know I I also with actors I I read
and see almost entirely
very good to Great actors when they
audition for me
the number of actors who auditioned for
me directly who are not good is probably
zero Because by the time I see them
they've been there's like a whole
process with the casting director and
everything and I so every time I'm
casting a movie every actor I see is
fantastic so every every time I have to
pick one I've insulting six others who
are spectacular and it feels terrible
I hate that part of the process my last
thing before getting into the movie
you've obviously been able to get
financing to make your movies but is
there a project that you've always
wanted to make that you struggled to
land the financing on meaning if you
could get the financing you make
anything you want what would you make
and why
I had always wanted to make
a an Epic film about the Russian
Revolution
um and uh Rasputin uh and uh the royal
family the Czar the tsar and this Arena
and uh
the scale of it would be quite large
and now I probably I I might be able to
scrape it together if I get like
legendarily fantastic people for
Rasputin and for Felix yusapov who
killed him which is a great part too and
all of that uh but now because of the
terrible situation in Ukraine and with
Putin uh I I don't think I would shoot
it anywhere else but Russia I was so
excited when Russia finally opened up
that I would be able to do it and maybe
somehow scrape together the money but
now that door is closed at least for the
foreseeable future so it would be that
one and I had a an idea of how to do it
which was you know Rasputin and the
person who killed him and the two
stories are told uh
apart from each other and then they they
come together at the end because you
know a Rasputin was they attempted to
kill him several times it was not an
easy person to to execute then this and
the the story is truly amazing
did you have a title for it the dream of
a thousand men was called
um jumping it's why I get to talk to you
uh how did you decide on the title
Armageddon time
I had remembered Reagan and other
politicians too talking ad nauseam about
possibilities of nuclear Armageddon and
about the and end of end of days really
and there was a TV movie called the day
after which played three years after I
think was 1983 although you forget these
things but I think that was the date but
it was very much early 80s in the air
late 70s especially after the Russians
invaded Afghanistan in 1980
that if the times felt extremely
dangerous sadly it's come back a little
bit that feeling uh because of the the
situation in Ukraine and 911 too I had a
certain unease you know did Al Qaeda
have a nuclear weapon that kind of thing
and that struggle that constant fear uh
of Armageddon weighed on my brother and
me as kids and then I also got really
into the clash in 1980 and they had a
song called Armageddon time which
actually is a cover by a reggae artist
named Willie Williams which was the
version I tried to use in the movie
Stephen but it's a it's a major key the
in the reggae version so a lot of people
won't get no supper tonight it's very
upbeat even if the lyrics are not
and The Clash we recorded it and Joe
Strummer sings it obviously with much
more danger and threat than Willie
Williams did
so his voice became a lot of people
won't get no sepa tonight it's kind of
like plaintiff whale and uh it worked
great against picture
and there was that Confluence of events
right that the movie uh had me grappling
with Reagan's election and the and his
constant talk of Armageddon and my love
for the clash and that whole cultural
movement so and the title seemed fitting
you know it's this catastrophe for the
kid it's a catastrophe for the country
it's maybe a catastrophe for the species
and of and the social justice content of
that song A lot of people won't get no
supper tonight A lot of people won't get
no justice tonight remember to kick it
over
no one will guide you Armageddon time
like the whole point of the song
is to emphasize a certain
desperation for large swaths of the
population
so it felt like it had power to me that
way one of the things that I thought you
did such a great job with one of the
many things is I feel like I was
actually there in that time period the
way that you are able to recall these
little moments
um do you have one of those Vivid
memories where you can remember things
from your childhood
um or do you know what I mean something
that the link ladder does very well with
his movies is his memory is just like
staggering the way he can recall his
childhood like you know what days are
confused or yeah by the way I think
Dazed and Confused is a masterpiece by
the way I 100 agree with you yeah
um I think I told him that once and I
think he thought
I was like
shining him I said a lovely guy Rick
link letter and I think I think he
thought I was like lying or something
and I kept saying no no no it's a master
and I I couldn't understand why he
he wouldn't accept the compliment
um yeah I do have my wife makes fun of
me for it I have a very good memory I
remember all of my grade school teachers
I remember every kid that I went to
school with practically I remember
my brother does too by the way and I
relied on him also for things like you
know the family plates which we got you
know we got this the white plates with
the green floral pattern on the edge and
so my brother told me about those I said
oh yeah so we got the art Department to
find them but we both have very good
memories on those kinds of details and I
made sure to try and include them as
much as I could because you know but
part of the look I I I'm not gonna just
say Twitter is just [ __ ] because it's
not there are many people who have
actually mastered Twitter and there are
people who might I'm not on Twitter but
my my daughter and my wife are and they
will show me absolutely hilarious things
that people write post incredibly witty
incredibly smart like it's really
amazing but one of the negative things
about Twitter is that it has encouraged
some people to generalize massively
and that's what leads to a kind of a a
ferocity towards art that I think is not
always warranted so what do I mean
I mean you could reduce uh any movie to
the most Bare Bones nonsensical sounding
or even politically inappropriate idea
yeah another movie that glorifies the
mafia you know and that movie could be
the Godfather
so so so knowing that this was a movie
where you could generalize like oh
another coming-of-age story or another
movie where you know a white kid and a
black kid are friends or whatever I
don't even know what generalization you
would bring to it knowing that that is
dominant now in large sections of the
culture
I decided to make sure that the details
were where the movie lived and died and
to get them as right as I could and to
bring as much of that to almost make it
the anti-social Network movie
uh
uh because you'd have to see it
you know that you couldn't describe the
Six Million Dollar lunch box The Six
Million Dollar Man lunch box or the type
of chandelier that we had or the school
uniform patches so that you know the the
car that we drove all that stuff does
matter
you know I'm just I'm I'm gonna
not to get too pretentious on you but I
so forgive this but I I did uh was lucky
enough to get a chance to direct an
opera a marriage of Figaro by Mozart in
Paris of right before the world ended in
2019
and you realize like okay Marriage of
Figaro is written a long time ago
and written at the end of the 18th
century and it's probably been performed
a gajillion times right so what is it
that you can bring to it well you can
say Marriage of Figaro now performed
inside the New York subways or you can
do it the way Mozart and depante wanted
you to do it but make sure that the
characters are acting and the set has as
much detail as possible detail matters
detail is what separates good from bad
so we tried to bring as much of that as
we could you made a statement about the
movie and you said I love the people in
this story they are all ghosts now and
that really hit me because I thought
about my childhood which this movie
really hit me with my own growing up is
very similar
um but I really that statement of they
are all ghosts now uh did you feel more
pressure making this then perhaps
everything else you've done just because
you our brain to life these people from
your past that meant such a great deal
to you
it's hard to say every time I make a
film I feel like my world is going to
end every time I make a film I'm
terrified
and I imagine uniquely
a an ocean of hatred so I I always feel
that pressure I guess I did this time I
felt the obsessive need to get it
accurate
I I hadn't always which sounds weird I I
remember I was
very involved with the details on Lost
City of Z2 and also at Astra like this
light switches the switches on the
spacecraft all that stuff yes
but that's a different order of
magnitude because this is
you're Reviving The Spirit of people who
are gone at the time I made it by the
way my father was still alive
my father died
uh while I was editing the movie uh of
covid and uh that had its own
melancholic effect
on the film and how I treated the
subject
and I did feel I mean I still feel a
kind of nerves
because my brother whom I adore hasn't
seen the movie yet he's gonna see it in
New York Film Festival and you know my
my kids said oh have you warned Uncle Ed
I'm very close to him by the way now I
talk to him all the time have you worn
Uncle Ed that he just beats you up in
the movie but I I I I I said no but but
you know that's in some ways an
expression of love I think what he does
in the movie is an expression of love
where he basically says don't talk
you know he's trying to protect him
so uh
uh yes the answer your question is yes
obviously I didn't think it at the time
but now that you asked me that and I
think about my reactions to it and how I
treated the subject it's very clear that
I did you worked with obviously Jeremy
is always fantastic but um Jeremy
obviously is very uh even more method
and he's you know uh I'm just curious
what are you like on set when you are
directing actors do you typically like
to give them a word or two about a
performance are you pulling them aside
and you sort of really like having a
full-on conversation what do you like as
a director when you are trying to get
your actor to get to a certain place
there is no one tried and true approach
I don't think to working with actors
because so many actors have a different
process
um my level of discourse or no I
shouldn't say level discourse might the
way that I talk with uh uh you know
Joaquin Phoenix is very different than I
would talk with Tony Hopkins which is
very different than how I would talk
with Jeremy or Annie uh and certainly
very different is how I would talk with
uh Vanessa Redgrave it's it has to do
with understanding their process first
and once I get a window into how they
work
I view the director's job as being
helpful how can I help the actor that's
really it I don't think it's more than
that by the way that itself is very
difficult how do you help the actor so
usually I talk to them very little
before take one after the rehearsal
process in rehearsal and my rehearsal I
really mean discussion we talk about the
character a ton and then I sort of walk
away and I don't talk to the actor at
all before take one
take one reveals a lot to me uh
I have to say more often than not I use
take one in the movie I love take one
take one is when great accidents and
weird things happen that you don't
expect
and that's usually quite magical
but sometimes if the actor is going in a
direction that I don't prefer
uh what I will do is I'll try to keep
the direction fairly simple
I'll try to keep to some aspect of
tangible like you don't like him you
know in a scene or or I'll say uh you
know here in this scene the other person
uh you don't believe her or him or them
you know something that allows them to
see or hear you're doing it with relish
you enjoy it you know that kind of thing
well then I will say uh I remember with
Tony I would give him just key words I
would say I said to him I said
this scene is like a benediction for the
boy
and he'd say ah okay Ben's actually yes
and then he would do it another way and
I've worked with such great people that
they usually do
they take to these simple directions
very well
sometimes it gets more complicated
sometimes I have to get more specific
but if that's the case it often means
there's something wrong with the scene
or how I've conceived of it
because the level of actor I work with
is so good
that it it's
it it's it's usually reveal the problem
with the script is usually revealed on
that note I need to stop I could ask you
a thousand other things but uh not today